arriving just weeks before avengers
endgame hits the big screen captain
Marvel's origins story is crucial to
understanding how the surviving Avengers
will regroup and take down the mad Titan
Thanos yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm
Jan and now that captain Marvel's movie
is out we've got some juicy details on
her powers and where they come from and
when you dig deeper there's some very
compelling evidence hidden in the Marvel
canon about how Carol Danvers very
particular power set will be key to
defeating Thanos and Avengers end game
obviously the spoilers ahead for Captain
Marvel so take care if you haven't seen
it yet the big reveal in Captain Marvel
is that Carol Danvers acquires her
extraordinary powers when she blows up
an engine that was created using power
from the tesseract Carol destroys the
experimental Lightspeed engine to
prevent the technology falling into the
hands of the Kree but when the device
explodes Carol's body absorbs the energy
which imbues her with superhuman powers
after Carol gets knocked out from the
blast she's abducted by the Korean taken
to hala as Yan Roxy's her powers as a
means of accessing the power of the
tesseract Carol gets an infusion of
creeped Lert which crucially gives her
additional powers at the Korean joy such
as super strength durability and stamina
remember for example in guardians of the
galaxy the Kree Ronan was able to hold
one of the Infinity stones directly in
his own hands without any injury so
Carol Danvers not only has a glowing
fist that can emit photon blast but she
also has a hidden power set that remains
locked away until the end of the movie
when she realizes that the curia have
been deliberately holding her back and
dampening her powers by the chip in her
neck she pulls it out unleashing her
full powers in the final showdown
between Carol and Ronan we see the full
power said she absorbed from the
tesseract on display she can smash
through a series of ballistic warheads
Superman's style as well as completely
take out an enormous creep acyl ship
with ease plus you can now fly through
space and survive without the need of
protection from a spaceship in the
comics these abilities referred to as
binary powers which give her access to
the energies of a white hole and
therefore the ability to control heat
gravity and electromagnetism so how will
carol danvers tesseract powers help her
and the Avengers defeat Thanos well for
the answer to that
we need to think back to another Marvel
character who also derives her powers
from an infinity stone in the
post-credits scene of Captain America
the Winter Soldier we got our first
introduction to Scarlet Witch in
Quicksilver Hydra we using the power of
the meinster which was contained and
Loki's scepter to experiment on the
twins giving them superhuman abilities
Scarlet Witch showed off some of these
powers and some truly badass moments
during infinity war Burt's more
crucially she also used her powers in a
last-ditch attempt to stop Thanos from
collecting all six Infinity stones when
she destroyed the mine stone lodged in
visions forehead at least temporarily
because Wanda's powers originate in the
mine stone she was the only one in the
avengers team who could perform this
task I've been giving a good deal of
thought to this entity in my head about
its nature but also its composition I
think if it were exposed to a
sufficiently powerful energy source
something very similar to its own
signature its molecular integrity could
fail and that's exactly why it's so
important that Carol Danvers received
her powers from the tesseract aka the
space stone if we look at what Scarlet
Witch was able to do to the mine Stern
an infinity war we can assume that
Captain Marvel could do something
similar to the space stone an endgame
for example carol's photon blast likely
have an energy signature similar or
identical to the space stone which
currently sits in Thanos's Infinity
Gauntlet so she could therefore destroy
the space stone when she goes up against
Thanos in endgame wrecking the space
stone could severely hinder Thanos the
starters' by preventing him from
teleporting between locations on top of
that in infinity war we witnessed how
the mad Titan used the space stone in
combination with other Infinity stones
to particularly lethal effect for
example he used it with the power stone
to tear apart Titans moon and rain down
meteors onto the heroes in Wakanda
Thanos employed the space stone to make
banners Hulkbuster phased through him
and then encased him in rock Dallas also
used it as a defense against ammo from
war machine as well a scarlet witch's
energy blast and he also used it early
in the film to freeze Loki's arm and
dagger when the god of mischief tried to
double-cross the mad Titan and kill him
which means the loss of this particular
stone would
if Nana's vulnerable against some
attacks he previously was able to
withstand and if this time Thor or
someone else landed a potentially deadly
blow on the mad Titan he wouldn't be
able to port himself away like he did in
infinity war what's especially
interesting also is that in the comics a
former Captain Marvel once destroyed the
comic book equivalent of the tesseract
when it was in the hands of Thanos in
the comics Captain Marvel's a superhero
Monica that's been taken up by many
individuals before Carol Danvers and the
very first Captain Marvel was the alien
crew warrior Marvel in Captain Marvel
issue 33 after acquiring the Cosmic Cube
Dallas gained Dominion and control over
the universe however Marvel aka Captain
Marvel was able to destroy the Cosmic
Cube removing the power that Thanos had
acquired and restoring the universe
connecting these Clues I can see it's
likely we'll see Captain Marvel destroy
or disable the space stone in endgame
and it could well be that this is the
moment when the Avengers get the upper
hand on Thanos and defeat him once and
for all destroying the space stone would
hold some special resonance in the MCU
as the tesseract was off first
introduction to the power of the
Infinity stones and has played a major
role throughout the franchise in Captain
America the First Avenger when Red Skull
tried to handle the tesseract directly
the artifact opened up a portal and
banished the villain to Fumiya where he
was cursed to watch over the soul stone
the tesseract was also a major part of
the first Avengers movie and of course
it made an important reappearance when
Loki stole it again in Thor Ragnarok and
then had to hand it over to Thanos an
infinity war so it would be especially
fitting if Marvel ended this phase of
its cinematic universe by destroying the
very first MacGuffin that has taken fans
on this epic journey the one problem
with this is that if Captain Marvel does
destroy the space stone then Thanos
could simply wind the clock back with
the time stone like he did with Scarlet
Witch to restore the mine stone but
Thanos may not be able to repeat that
trick in endgame after all the Infinity
Gauntlet was damaged during the snap and
the time stone may well have been
affected plus we don't know what the
consequences might be for Thanos having
meddled with time in infinity war and
there could be something that will stop
him doing that again remember after all
that dr. strange was told in his
there were consequences for messing
around with time you still think there
will be no consequences strange no price
to pay we broke our rules just like the
bill comes deal always now do you think
Captain Marvel will be able to destroy
the space stone with her tesseract
powers and do you have any other
theories on how the MC News newest hero
will help the Avengers defeat Thanos let
me know in the comments below if you
enjoy deep dives theories and
behind-the-scenes secrets about your
favorite movies be sure to subscribe and
tap the bell to get all my new videos
for my next Captain Marvel video tap
left or tap right for another video
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers